hey guys Pete here this is my Game of
Thrones season 7 episode 3 full recap
and review quick spoiler check it's time
for you to get out of here if you
haven't watched episode 3 yet because
this video will be a spoiling experience
if you haven't watched it if you're not
familiar with my channel I do a
scene-by-scene recap first it's pretty
thorough and then I discussed the whole
thing afterwards it can get a bit long
because there's a lot to talk about so I
put a timestamp link in the description
for those of you who want to bypass the
scene-by-scene business and get straight
to the afterthought with that out of the
way let's get into it we open with
John's landing at Dragonstone straight
away there's a playful exchange where
tyrion calls John the bastard of
Winterfell and he comes back with the
dwarf of Casterly Rock
they smile catch up and davos is
formally introduced to tyrion the sandy
turned things in a more formal direction
and then asked them to turn over their
weapons which they do as they believe
the beasts tablo's asked her where she's
from and gets very little response and
this prompts him to say to John that
this place has changed as they start
their ascent to the castle Tyrion ask
John about Sansa saying he hear she's
alive and well while jokingly asking if
she misses him terribly while they're
walking they cover some ground and
filling each other and Tyrion assures
John his marriage to Sansa was a sham
and unconsummated he says she's much
smarter than she lets on John says that
she's starting to let on and that his
bannermen think he's a fool for coming
Tyrion says of course they do if he was
his hand that he was advised against it
for sure
and the general rule of thumb is that
stark men don't fare well when they head
south which John agrees with but he
brings up the fact that he's not
actually a stark a dragon ends up flying
by and causes John and Davos to hit the
ground their escorts aren't fazed at all
and we see this shot where Davos looks
up to Sima sandy smiling as she looks at
the dragons flying above the cat
fool Tyrion helps Shawn up saying that
you never really get used to the dragons
and says come their mother is waiting
for you we see that Melisandre is
looking on from above and that Varys has
come to ask her why she hasn't gone to
receive their new guests she explains to
him that they didn't end things on good
terms because the terrible mistakes that
she made she also lets him know she's
decided to head to the lantus when he
says she shouldn't return to Westeros
she explains she will as she is fated to
die there just as he is now this was a
bit of a surprise because I was
expecting her to play some level of an
advisory role to won't really both of
these people John and Daenerys she tells
Varys says she's done her part bringing
ice and fire together but I'm inclined
to think that she's headed to volantis
for purpose rather than to sit things
out and wait to see what happens as a
quick reminder volantis is where Jorah
katnappe tyrion from the brothel in
season five it's where Robb Stark's wife
Talisa came from and most importantly
here it's very Lord of Light friendly
kind of place the red God and priests
and priestesses are very popular in the
city especially among the slave
population
I think it's notable here that there
seems to heed what she says about him
dying in Westeros in much the same way
he was kind of visibly affected in his
exchange with Ken vara before we cut
away from him he notices what's left of
the Greyjoy fleet limping in to land at
the beach below or at least that's the
impression we get at the time although
we don't have a lot of time to think
about that at all because the moment
we've been waiting for is finally upon
us we see John and Davos led into the
throne room where Daenerys is sitting
patiently waiting for them and even
though we've seen most of this from the
trailers at this point it was still an
awesome moment and it wasn't even made a
little better by the fact that miss
Bundy rattles off Danny's impressive
list of titles before Davos has to be
prompted to introduce John and then even
after that he kind of pauses as he
finishes before he realizes that he
probably should mention that oh yeah
John
the king in the north by the way
Jonathan Eris exchanged pleasantries
briefly before getting down to the
business of John bending the knee I
talked about this in great detail and
the whole scenario in a previous video
so I won't rehash the whole details of
that but it pretty much goes like you
think it would she brings up the fact
that his ancestor Torrance dark the king
who now bent the knee to egg on and
basically pledged fealty for perpetuity
obviously John doesn't bend the knee and
here are the points that the two
exchanged in there back and forth how
stark was pledged to House Targaryen
after the conquest
Daenerys his father burned John's
grandfather and uncle alive
Daenerys doesn't believe the daughter
should be held responsible for the
crimes of the father John doesn't
believe that he should be held to the
oaths of his ancestors Daenerys wants to
know why he's there if not to bend the
knee and become warden of the north
he points out that they need each
other's help she points out that he
probably saw the Dragons when he came in
in the Dothraki horde so she really
doesn't need his help
John addabbo say that yeah you're right
you could you could have crushed King's
Landing without our help so that's not
it and they reckon the only reason she
hasn't done that so far is because she
doesn't want to kill innocent people
then John breaks into what we're going
to call crazy talk because that's how
the people on the South perceived this
and he tells her about the white Walker
threat what she doesn't really
comprehend now it gets really good when
she rises and makes a very credible
point or points about her path to where
she is and the fact she tasks dragons
which nobody else has been able to do
for quite some time the gravity of this
came out a lot more to me on my second
watch but you can see the problem really
clearly here she's following what she
believes to be her destiny in Davos as
counterpoint about John's equally
impressive journey to where he is makes
it impossible for these two to team up
at this point now John does stop Davos
when he he stops in short when he starts
to tell about his resurrection but I
think it's safe to say that each side
planted seeds before they all get
interrupted by varus entering the room
in a few minutes of course before that
happens
Tyrion nearly begs John to bend the knee
making some pretty good points but John
sort of pulls out some spine and you
know that part is exactly received well
by Daenerys she mentions that she's the
rightful queen in the Seven Kingdoms in
that sense he won't bend the knee that
means he's an open rebellion
but then beerus comes in so she
basically apologizes that she has to cut
it short sends them off he's not really
her prisoner yet so on and so forth
after they leave the spider explains
what happened to the fleet and then we
transitioned to seeing Theon being
fished out of the water on deck he
explains that Yara has been captured by
urine and the crew basically ends up
walking away from him in disgust and
there was a lot of talk about Theon and
his decision to jump overboard rather
than die trying to fight against his
uncle in the last episode I mentioned
that he basically proved himself as a
coward and several people left comments
saying that they thought that he made
the right decision this is what stood
out to me right here I mean you can make
a good argument for him doing what he
did or point out the trauma that he
experienced under Ramsay and all that
other stuff but like I said in the in
the last recap to the other Greyjoy's
he's proved himself a coward and we see
that here it doesn't matter to them if
it was the right choice or not that's
their way of life and that's the way
they see things so Deon's on the outs
right now I mean he's shivering on the
deck and none of the people there care
why on the other end of the Greyjoy
scale we see that his uncle is in a much
happier state as he drags his prisoners
through King's Landing the small folks
seem to love him and hate his captives
which he points out to Yara look at them
cheering for a Greyjoy which is pretty
insane when you think about it once they
entered the throne room the seriousness
of the situation for these women is
illustrated in the face of alaria when
she sees the mountain you're on does his
stick and Lena Headey absolutely owns
the scene with her reaction to ilaria
when she spits on the ground
for house key strings you're on to say
that he's going to get what he desires
with the quick change of direction and
then after the war is won it's a really
great sequence and we see that things
are looking up for the crown in general
you're on needles Jamie with his little
chance when they stand next to each
other before we cut away first about how
the people loved him and Jamie would
really know about that would he
and then about how to make love to
Cersei in that exchange Jamie reminds
him that those people were after his
sister during her walk of shame not all
that long ago and we get a nice
realization that actually it doesn't
actually matter whose heads are on a
pike you know the small folk just like
severed heads as you're on points out he
then takes a bow he rolls out with y'all
still in tow next we learn what Cersei
had planned out for her new prisoners
the exchange here is fantastic and we
learned that Circe's level of brutality
is amazing as we're sitting there
scratching her heads about why her lips
look so strange we see her deliver the
kiss to tyene and know just what she had
in mind you can't help feel for ilaria
here who is absolutely a child murderer
herself the wickedness involved on both
sides here is crazy and in the end we
know that she'll be kept alive forcibly
if necessary to watch her daughter die
of the poisoning that was just delivered
and not just that she'll be there long
after the Long Goodbye poison does its
job
she'll be there for the rest of her life
and Cersei points out you're gonna watch
your daughter rot and then turn to dust
harsh this apparently turns the Queen on
because she goes to visit Jaime and they
make out for a moment and then she goes
down on him to cap off a long day we see
them wake up the next morning in her
chambers we see that he's watching her
sleep which is kind of a gentle moment
for this I guess and then someone comes
to the door he protests about her
answering it but she points out that
she's the queen of the seven key
and she can do whatever she wants the
servant who comes to the door is
actually someone we've seen before but
I'll talk about that more in one of the
follow-up videos it's really not that
important Circe's visitor is taiko no
stars from the iron bank which I can't
help thinking is Mycroft Holmes every
time I watch one of the scene this is a
good exchange between the two where he
lays out their position and she counters
pretty much everything he says by
channeling her in her time would in the
end they agree for him to wait two weeks
and she promises that he'll be paid back
back at Dragonstone we get a good John
and Tyrion theme where the latter clips
that he came up there to brood but now
since John looks better at brooding than
he does he started like he's a failure
of brooding which is kind of funny the
main points here are though that Tyrion
failed to see the Greyjoy attack coming
John was to leave to get his people
ready for the war that's coming everyone
told John not to come but he did anyways
and now he looks like a full Tyrion
points out that Daenerys his cause is
true that she protects people from
monsters just like he does and that you
can't you can't really expect her to
drop everything that's going on to fight
an army of an enemy she's never seen for
a man that she doesn't know it's an
unreasonable request but is there
anything that he can do to help and the
next team he explains to Daenerys that
she should just give him some dragon
glass because it's worthless to her
anyways give him something by giving him
nothing basically she asks what he
thinks about the White Walkers and the
knight King stuff and he says he
believes him because he actually came
there against the advice of all his
advisers he came south and that has to
mean something
then she asked about what Davos meant by
taking a knife in the heart where his
people and Tyrion basically just brushes
that off after that we get the
much-anticipated one-on-one conversation
between Jon and Daenerys she moves a
little in his direction allowing him to
mine the dragon glass but won't go all
the way to say she believes him about
the night king she reinforces her stance
to remove Searcy from the Iron Throne
which he says he wouldn't expect her not
to do that and I was just reading this
doing the screenshots and I gotta say
the fanboy inside of me really came out
when she says you better get to work Jon
Snow I mean hell hearing her say that
name and I mean it's a long time in the
making right so this was pretty awesome
you gotta say after that we check in on
Winterfell we see that Sansa is taking
up the reins and John's absence and
doing a pretty good job of it after
tasking those around her with stuff that
he does she ends up with Littlefinger
and he tries to school her a little bit
I mentioned in the trailer breakdown
already so I won't go too deeply into it
but Sansa is becoming very likeable and
you know she handles him you get the
idea that she'll take what's useful from
what he says and not really be swept up
in all his self-serving nonsense luckily
their interaction does not last that
long and they're interrupted by brands
return now honestly this is where
especially on the second launch the
episode gets sort of trainwreck for me I
mean overall I think it's one of the
best episodes of late but from here on
out things get noticeably worse than the
first half I'm a huge fan of Brandon his
path in the story and this reunion was
awesome right up to the point where they
start talking on some levels I mean
either way it's nice to see him that he
made it back and too rushed and weird or
not that's a good thing he seems to be a
bit robotic these days though and I
don't know he can only explain a little
bit to Santa and then he promptly freaks
her out by talking about her wedding
night she goes back inside and we
learned that this is where that shot
came from the trailers and that he's
going to stay there a little while
longer I don't know there's just a
little underwhelming
after that we go back over to the
Citadel and find out that Sam did indeed
cure Jorah I mentioned that I thought he
might get better quick in my salmon
Dora's purpose video from last week but
I wasn't expecting him to make a full
recovery overnight and that's exactly
what happened so basically Ambrose says
hey you can go you're fun you're not
infected anymore and as predicted he
says he is headed to see Daenerys Sam
extends his hand for a handshake which
is pretty cool when you think about it
because it's been a long time since
Jorah could touch anyone so it's not bad
to have your first handshake after being
cured with Sam ever Rose had told Sam
that he would speak to him later and
when they talk he says that he pulled
off a very difficult procedure and
should be proud which is very unexpected
then he tells him he has to copy this
huge pile of scrolls and manuscripts
because they're rotting apart and he
should be glad to do it because he
actually should get kicked out for what
just happened then we get a short scene
where Daenerys wants to take her dragons
and think you're on fleet but everybody
else there advises against it and this
is a problem right she's too important
to be flying around by herself on dragon
back and no one else can go along or
ride the Dragons instead I mean that's
just how it is right they talk about
Casterly Rock and then we go there the
sequence was edited in a way that it's
enjoyable to watch you hear Tyrians
voice over and he's telling Daenerys
what the son saw it will be up against
as they use this tunnel that he knows
about and built to get inside the gates
which we saw all that in the trailers I
had to smile a little bit when we saw
that Tyrians bed is still sitting there
as they climb up out of the tunnel the
one who used to entertain his [ __ ] as
we watch grey worm cutting his way
through the defenders it sort of dawns
on us that they're able to take it a
little bit too easily compared to what
Tyrion is describing and you know they
say hey there should be more people here
they're not here he looks over the wall
sees your own attacking the rest of
their fleet he picks up a dying
Lannister soldier and asks where the
rest of them are and we cut to see them
marching in formation we see that
they've come to sack Highgarden and even
though there's some dead soldiers and
things we don't actually see the attack
it just basically looks like Jamie walks
right in he tells Alayna upstairs that
there is that you know they fought as
well as can be expected
and we get her swan song basically
pretty simply the Lannisters gave up
Casterly Rock because the forces of the
Targaryen army wouldn't be able to hold
it anyways we already learned in the
past that the gold had dried up there
from Tywin so after the plan for your on
to come in and burn their fleet they're
pretty much screwed they have to cross
the whole continent to get back and now
the crown gets all the valuable
resources they need from taking over the
Terrell's and their home so in the end
he lets her take poison so she does just
that but make sure to go out with a bang
by telling him that was her that poison
Joffrey
as soon as Jaime says he made sure
there'd be no pain in her death she
tells him it was her that put that plan
in motion all along and if you're a fan
of Elena I suppose this was a fitting
end of her story as she really lays it
on heavy as she describes how she killed
Jamie's firstborn and watching him choke
his hands on his neck as he's choking to
death and you know she wants him to pass
this on to Cersei because she wants her
to know that she was the one who did it
from there we cut to the credits and the
episode ends I think this was a good
episode especially the first half and I
think I found myself in a place where I
can just accept some of the things that
were really bothering me last season
when it started out but I'll get to that
at the end so if you didn't watch the
beginning scene-by-scene welcome to the
video some of the main points that I
took notes on the Melisandre thing was
surprising that she's just taking
herself out of the story at this point
so what do you guys think she's up to
there I really don't see her staying
away I mean I know she said she's coming
back to die but what is she going to do
in the meantime like I feel like she has
a purpose there Jonathan Harris is
meetup lived up to the hype I mean
especially on the second watch Dan and
Dave and the director Mark Malad they
nailed this it was really good like for
the amount of anticipation that's
involved with something like this it's
really hard to say that nothing about it
suck but really nothing about it sucked
I mean it was really as a fan of the
Joe and then watching it again with the
critical eye I mean I enjoyed it
the dialogue was fantastic the acting
was fantastic everything was good one
thing I really liked about this episode
I think and I noticed this in his scenes
where he was kind of going back and
forth between a Daenerys that was losing
her patience with John is Tyrion has
pretty much gone back to his old self
like the old Tyrion that isn't just
around to joke about [ __ ] like he he was
one of my favorite characters as I think
most people but in the last couple of
seasons you know his story is just kind
of it's gotten away from that let's just
put it that way in this episode I really
enjoyed the way that he it was reading
the situation he was coming up with ways
to keep things without exploding and I I
don't know I'm glad to see that he's
back to that instead of the whole like
hey trying to make jokes and drink with
grey worm and the sandy I thought it was
interesting that Tyco brought up the
fact that you're on wooden ships
wouldn't do so well against the Dragons
it kind of shows how easily Daenerys
could have rolled over Westeros if she
had brought the heat like that of course
those downsides are real there will be a
lot of people that were dying King's
Landing especially but it reminds me at
the end of the season last year we you
know everyone was sort of taking stock
on like how thirsty would actually be
able to hold King's Landing for a second
once
Daenerys landed and it didn't really
come up that she would it would be her
caution that you know following
directions from her advisors that would
be the great equalizer cuz on paper I
mean she looked like she was going to
roll over Westeros and right now she's
not so I thought that was pretty
interesting also Daenerys obviously
seems to be warming up to John's cause
but the story as such has things in a
way that she's never going to be able to
peel away from what a war was Cersei for
the Seven Kingdoms so that's good I mean
even though the battles are a little bit
unrealistic in the way that they're
getting where they have to get to and
all that stuff like it is a bind and
based on what
in common the next episode from what we
can tell from the trailer things will
probably even out a little bit there the
reference to maester Luwin keeping a
copy of every Raven scroll seems
important we saw in the trailer again
that Littlefinger may be up to some
treachery whenever they the unsheathing
of the Kasbah blade there and some
people pointed out at the end of the
trailer when she's looking at those
papers that maybe that is those old
scroll records that she's looking at so
there's some speculating to do there
like what might she find the brand thing
I mean like I don't know maybe I'm being
unrealistic since I am a huge brand
bloodraven part of the story fan what
did you guys think about it to me it
seemed rush I don't like the idea that
he can just see everything all the time
so much like I mentioned that in the
first trailer breakdown that I was
hoping that he can't just roll back in
his head whenever he feels like it and
see everything and it looks like that
might be the case or that they had him
download the entirety of history or
something I don't know I'm not willing
to put that aside yet and say all the
messed up brand story completely but for
something as big as his return to
Winterfell it was underwhelming to say
the least let's hope that goes in a
better direction I'm happy he's there
don't get me wrong all those scrolls and
manuscripts that Sam was looking at I
have to imagine that there's something
in there that he's going to find
otherwise what's the point of them being
there I thought it was a little bit odd
that they didn't kick him out of the
Citadel honestly
but since they gave him that pile of
stuff that means that they wanted him to
be there to find something in that right
I mean where else can we go there he has
to find out some knowledge about
something I mean he's not really going
to end up being a maester I don't think
that just there's not enough time for
that so I was glad that he did cure
Jorah I did do a whole video about that
last week and I do think that jor will
be important as far as bringing the
forces together what to see how that
plays out yeah and the big thing is I
mentioned right the beginning of this
like
just no way that some of this stuff
could happen you're on being at Casterly
Rock and the big one and you know last
year this kind of stuff was really
bugging me and I think like the best way
that I have to deal with it is just hey
you know this is the story this is
what's going to happen just forget about
that stuff and enjoy it and mostly I
think I can I just think that the second
half of this episode just seemed kind of
rushed you know what I mean like the
first half was fantastic I mean all of
the dialogue everything it was just
great and then the second half like all
these things happen like boom boom boom
and it was a little too fast for me but
tell me what you think in the comments
and please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and set
notifications I've been doing a full
schedule Game of Thrones
since the season started and I plan to
keep on doing that I'll have a couple
follow-up preview videos before the next
episode airs go back and watch my video
on the Hound if you haven't watched that
since he wasn't in this episode it is
still completely relevant so that's cool
please follow me on Twitter and thanks
for watching guys I'll talk to you soon